hello
the fans are screaming the Jonas
Brothers are back how do you feel pretty
good this has been an amazing entrance
and it's we're so ecstatic that so many
people showed up so this is overwhelming
[Applause]
[Music]
how is it to have them here tonight have
they helped you guys as a band dream
came true they're all so busy that the
fact that they actually get to come here
and support us like this means the world
one day off
we don't take act like it had been
nearly six years since we'd spent time
together just the three of us as
brothers do you really open up in this
documentary how important was it for you
to heal that way together as brothers I
think for us it was it was important to
step into this new chapter with a lot of
clarity about how we were going to
approach it and that was being as honest
as possible with each other and with our
fans and maybe people that were not fans
as well which I think is very important
and this documentary hopefully will
bring some families back together that
perhaps have had some tough times any
moment when you thought your
relationships wouldn't fully recover
definitely was I think it took time but
after you know the initial shock of it
all we led to a better relationship and
then this documentary literally shows
the real come back together moment how
do you make sure that you stay in this
good place from here I think what we
learned over the last year and what the
doc shows quite a bit is that our
relationship as brothers as family comes
first and then the band that comes
second it's important to us obviously
but we have to make sure that we have a
healthy outlook on everything and then
ultimately makes us a lot more fun and
we enjoy the ride a lot more
[Music]
[Applause]